if there was any doubt remaining about
the relationship of WikiLeaks is Julian
Assange - the American right and Russia
and the Trump administration Julian
Assange has now been caught offering
dirt on a Democratic senator to someone
pretending to be right-wing Fox News
host sean hannity online i think you're
gonna like this story a woman named del
Gilliam started pretending to be sean
hannity online after a sean hannity's
actual twitter account temporarily went
offline and del got a direct message
back on Twitter from Julian Assange
himself she created an account Sean
Hannity and then I think it's like to
underscore two underscores and ended up
talking directly to Assange on Twitter
and it got to the point of Assange quote
setting up a meeting over other channels
for Assange to send Hannity who was
actually this woman Dell Gilliam news
about Senator Mark Warner meaning
Democratic Senator Mark Warner the top
Democrat on the Senate Intel committee
that is currently investigating Trump
Russia collusion and they actually went
as far as setting up a call for 9:30
a.m. Eastern Time about six hours after
the conversation took place we have the
screenshots the direct messages from
Twitter and you see fake Hannity saying
I can't believe this is happening I mean
I can it's crazy
nothing can be put past people I'm
exhausted from the whole night what
about you though you doing okay and
Assange says I'm happy as long as there
is a fight - which fake sean hannity
replies I'm definitely up for a fight
you up for a call at 9:30 Eastern to
which Julian Assange says yes you can
send me messages on other channels have
some news about Warner fake Hannity says
sounds good talk to you soon and Julian
Assange says take care what does this
tell us well it keeps building the
picture of WikiLeaks not as an unbiased
clearinghouse of information that they
carefully and responsibly redact
and publish without regard to political
implications this is an actor that is
working either deliberately or as useful
idiots and useful idiots is not an ad
hominem it's a very specific term with a
precise meaning for the furtherance of
Russian propaganda and/or the benefit of
the Trump administration before the idea
was Hassan says we are contact for the
Democratic leaks wasn't part of the
Russian state and we ultimately found
out the letter of that was true but
there were NGO betweens there and
information that was released by
WikiLeaks did at some point come from
Russian individuals or those working on
behalf of Russian actors later Julian
Assange claimed well you know our
sources are anonymous we have an
anonymizing system for submitting
documents and data so we don't actually
know who submits data to us well then
how could he have been so sure that the
people submitting data and documents to
Wikileaks weren't working on the behalf
of the Russian government it really
didn't make any sense we later learned
that during the Trump campaign Julian
Assange was communicating directly
directly with Donald Trump jr. and
talking about possible dirt that they'd
be able to provide and the timing of
those messages with Trump jr. was also
suspicious when compared to public
timelines about statements from Trump
and his campaign and now the cherry on
top we find out that Julian Assange was
eager to pass along suppose a dirt about
a Democratic senator a senator who is
involved in the investigation of Trump
Russia collusion to someone he believed
to be Sean Hannity a hyper partisan
ideological conservative Fox News host a
little odd to me though because you'd
think that Julian Assange would be a
little bit more tech savvy as he
obviously is I mean you can check to see
whether or not the Twitter account has
like a verification yes mark sure and
maybe he was trying to like plan this
double switch to turn the tables around
and trick the other person maybe it
occurred to me but if that's true
wouldn't we have heard about it by now
possibly yeah I don't know it's it's not
like this just broke an hour ago if the
hoax made it to 9:30 a.m. Eastern Time
it would've been great to see like how
she would carry it out like would she
use a sean hannity soundboard perhaps I
have no idea I have no idea and I think
she didn't even know the answer
that because she never expected it to
get this far it was sort of created as a
parody account and it's since been
deactivated by Twitter is that right
yeah so listen bottom line when you look
at the behavior of WikiLeaks and Julian
Assange this is not how an unbiased
publisher of relevant political
documents behaves period this is how
partisan activists behave and that's
okay I don't have a problem with people
being partisan activists as long as we
understand and agree that that's what
they are period today's program is
sponsored in part by wink spelled wi and
c wink makes it easy for you to discover
great wines because every month they
ship you wines that have been matched to
your taste and personalized to you these
are wines that you're going to love and
they're shipped right to your door you
just open them and enjoy them and unlike
the grocery store which won't help you
select wines they won't deliver it to
your door with wink you get to explore
rare and interesting wines from around
the world and they're tailored to you
from the comfort of your home go to try
wink comm slash Pakman and fill out
their palate profile quiz they'll ask
you questions like how do you like your
coffee
do you like raspberries or blueberries
and then it will use your answers to
those questions to develop a taste
profile for you and you'll start getting
great wines personalized to you deliver
to your door and as you drink more wines
and rate more wines the wink system will
learn and continue to improve the
personalization of wines to bottles that
you will like no membership fees you can
skip any month you can cancel anytime
and they have a 100% satisfaction
guarantee
so you never pay for a bottle you don't
like and for a limited time you can save
$20 when you go to try wink comm slash
Pakman that's tri wink spelled T ry wi
and see.com forward slash Pakman for $20
off try wink comm slash Pakman